uh let's bring in kevin mccarthy
minority leader uh
congressman uh thanks for joining us uh
leader mccarthy
when you look at what where how this
story is going
uh chuck schumer says what's worse not
knowing or knowing and not doing
anything about it what do you
how do you answer them what i think is
worse is what chuck schumer is playing
into he's playing politics with american
lives by saying what he's saying
we all know that russia is dangerous to
america that's why this administration
the trump administration
changed from the obama administration of
a resetting
what he what the president did was gave
weapons to ukraine
what the president trump did is also put
sanctions on russia
president trump is doing everything he
can to protect
our american troops but the idea of
leaking information
not even knowing whether it's true or
not in the process
and playing it out in politics is
dangerous to all
americans who serve in our military
anywhere in the world
this is not a place for this chuck
schumer is part of the gang of eight
as myself as i am myself and this is not
the way we should handle this situation
or classified information
and play it out into politics well it
certainly is not
illegal for the new york times to print
the story and everybody has picked it up
but it is illegal whoever
inside the government did leak it to the
new york times essentially
but ultimately uh let's say it is true
leader mccarthy
and russia did pay and i know there's
some concern about whether or not a car
bombing in april of 2019 resulted in the
deaths of three marines
ultimately uh if it did happen and
russia did pay to have americans killed
what are we going to do to russia
well there would be many options of what
we could do to russia
the one thing you do have to find right
now find out if it is true
i know individuals are saying they have
questions on both sides let's get all
the information
and let's not play this out into the
public let's get the real information
so those on hand can do the actions that
we need to hold back
the one thing i do know that this
president has done though stronger
sanctions against russia
by any other president standing up to
him also giving ukraine weapons where
obama would only give them blankets
i mean let's handle this in the manner
in which we should making sure we're
protecting our troops first
and foremost that regardless whoever
ever looks at american troops that they
will have consequences for any actions
that they go after
so congressman i was talking to a friend
yesterday she's in georgia at sea island
and she said they're on the beach
and all their kids with all their kids
and they have to wear masks on the beach
and they're requiring that she said
they're burning up hot um but they're
requiring it and even the little ones
her little three-year-old has to wear
a mask she said it's it's annoying but
she wants to stay safe
in your home state of california they're
doing the same thing they're they're
actually closing the beaches
in some of in some parts of your state
for the july fourth weekend
shutting down bars now and mandating the
mass because we're seeing a rise in
cases
what's your advice for your home state
well for my home state i do believe in
wearing masks
i do not want to shut the economy back
down every day we learn
more information about this virus what
we're learning now is it's not being
passed
by our utensils and others what we
thought early it actually is the
droplets from individuals to another one
so wearing a mask social distancing not
touching your face and washing your
hands
is a way that we can continue the
economy opening up
in my home community it's not the bars
as much that is passing from the health
community telling me
it's from within their own homes so we
need to continue to practice the social
distances
yeah shelter in place is not going to
fly in this country again i hope
lawmakers realize that
but uh let's add to this and i don't
know what you do with this stat we get a
lot of this
but if you look at the deaths in this
country a month even two weeks ago
11 of all deaths were due to covet 19.
now
even though the cases are going up it
goes from 11 to seven
so more people are getting it and
surviving with it
number one it could be that maybe this
virus is not as severe this
this uh this this version of the virus
not as severe number two
younger people are getting it but they
survive it and they're immune to it
so is that a good thing well
a good thing would be nobody getting the
virus and that would be china not lying
to the rest of the world i mean the
study says 95
of this never would have happened had
china not lied well it is here now and
something we didn't invite here
the thing we are knowing as the american
ingenuity we're testing 600 000 people a
day
well more than 31 million no other
country can do that so as you test more
you will find more but what we're also
doing from our
health community and from our science
and medicine we're finding better ways
of
treatment and that's what you're finding
here that people are getting treated
faster because they're being tested
sooner
they'll be getting the treatment and
healthier as we go through this
one thing about america we will overcome
this we will find a vaccine we're
finding therapies for it
and we will we will actually not only
save america but save the rest of the
world from what china lied to us
and put havoc and death throughout this
world
yeah leader mccarthy um you've said that
everybody should wear a mask what about
the president
you know he's made it clear he doesn't
want to wear a mask but his federal
government says peop
everybody should wear a mask don't you
think it would be
a powerful symbol if the president of
the united states
would put on a mask and understand what
so many people around the
country are doing to try to slow down
the spread of this thing
remember i say we're a mass but when you
see me speak on the floor when nobody
else is around me
i'm not wearing a mask at that time when
you see the president speak
i think the social distancing i've known
the president to have worn masks at
times as he goes forward
i do think the health of the nation and
make sure
this economy down that is not the
approach to take
with the more information we have
knowledge today wearing the mask is the
best opportunity
for us to keep this economy open keep us
working keep us safe
and help us as we build towards that
vaccine
where we're in a much stronger position
than any other country before sure and
leader mccarthy you know
we actually all have to wear a mask to
get into this building when we go into
the green room we have to as well so we
take it off
when we're on tv just as you do when you
speak as well i
i just don't see any downside in the
president being seen more often
wearing it it's symbolic obviously it's
patriotic because you're not only
protecting yourself you're protecting
other people i've heard that there are
people around the president who say no
you shouldn't wear it
but nonetheless it would be a powerful
symbol
it would i mean for the fourth of july
we could all show our uh
patriotism with a red white and blue
mass going out there
so uh mr leader uh steve scalise was
tweeting out about the proxy vote thing
so nancy pelosi saying she's extending
the proxy vote she was doing it for 45
days she started it on may 20th and for
folks at home that don't know what that
is
it's where she's telling the folks in
the house that they can stay at home if
they don't feel comfortable coming to
washington
they can vote from home and they can uh
participate in their committee meetings
from home and correct me if i'm wrong
but that's what it is right
yes what it is is shadow voting what it
is is giving all your votes to nancy
pelosi
so if you voted for your member of
congress she or he
they no longer have the power they
turned it off to they turned it over to
nancy pelosi
they stay home they're getting paid for
not working
congress is essential we work through
yellow fever through the burning of this
cabinet so they're not even working
through
zoom because a lot of people are doing
this a lot of companies are doing this i
know republicans said it's
unconstitutional steve scalise says
um she's extending her proxy voting
scheme for another 45 days americans get
back to work dems extend their free pass
to skip work altogether
but are they not are they not working at
all
no they don't show up work in congress
means
you are the representative for your
district they have loaned you the power
they have loaned you the voice so who is
the voice for you if you go to congress
if you're not voting on the floor
another member walks up and says
kevin mccarthy wanted to vote this way
that's all the work you do
and if if you want to vote by proxy you
have to sign a letter that you're
physically unable to be here
well what did we find charlie crist said
he was unable to come to congress
but he got in the car and drove for two
and a half hours to try to
watch a launch of a spaceship
that's what he decided to do instead of
represent his people how
if you are not on the floor to give the
voice of your district
you miss the whole opportunity and that
becomes law right and if you're too much
of a high risk maybe you shouldn't run
for re-election
uh china in particular has now passed a
controversial security law
goodbye hong kong we have now witnessing
the takedown of that autonomous region
of china
that deal is done and we are going to
stop with our special status there in
response
what i feel is bad for the people of
hong kong they're essentially going to
be smothered by mainland china
it's not only bad for hong kong it's bad
for the world not only did china lie to
the entire world so thousands of people
have died
china has not only lied to the entire
world they put their name on a piece of
paper of a treaty of how they would
handle hong kong
for 50 years and now they just showed
they would never keep their word
when they built the islands and they
told obama that they'd never weaponized
them
they lied there too when they steal our
technology and say they do not they lie
there too
when they send people over into our
universities and we have to arrest them
when they're getting on the airplane
with our secrets they lie then too
and they lie when they pay for the
harvard professor
to steal the secrets inside the
technology that he was working on
do you know what they're doing to the
wake up do you know what they're doing
to the wiggers now
they're uh they are they are sterilizing
uh aborting and making them use iuds to
make sure that
that muslim population withers as if the
concentration camps they set up
aren't bad enough where's the world
condemnation there where's the muslim
community there
yeah you know what else they're doing to
australia australia simply wants to know
where did this virus come from let's
figure it out
they are punish them to even look at the
information
why did they not allow our scientists to
come in
and help contain this why did they
influence the world health organization
to lie to the rest of the world
so thousands of people have died well we
should step up for australia we should
fill in the iron ore that they're not
getting
and we should help them out with trade
they're our most arguably our most loyal
ally
hopefully the president will do that we
should also change our supply chain
where these companies come back to
america you know what else happens july
1st
usmca the strongest treaty you can find
when it comes to north america or
anywhere else in the world
so if you are a company inside china and
you're thinking about moving don't think
about
vietnam think about north america
absolutely i know japan is rising up
moving their supply chain back we should
do the same this is something that
president trump
warned us about not as candidate trump
but as citizen trump
all right this is what needs to happen
in the next administration
that's why he needs another four years
leader kevin mccarthy we thank you very
much
for your view from the top thank you sir
have a good uh
independence day week all right